[Música]
y en directo a llegó el momento de ir a
bolivia vamos a hablar con nuestra
corresponsal emery vacas sobre las
masivas protestas a favor del gobierno
que dice que la derecha busca
desestabilizarlo mary muy buenas noches
cuéntenos cómo transcurrió la jornada de
hoy
hola que tal buenas noches la jornada ha
estado repleta de manifestaciones en
favor del gobierno de luís arce y david
choquehuanca dos largas marchas se han
dirigido hacia el centro de la ciudad de
la paz y se han concentrado en la plaza
san francisco donde el presidente luís
arce ha dado un discurso para sus
seguidores en esta manifestación han
participado sectores sociales que apoyan
al movimiento al socialismo como los
mineros los cocaleros los
interculturales también ha estado
presentes los ministros acompañados de
sus funcionarios y ellos han explicado
que han acudido esta marcha luego de
pedir un día de vacación pues la
oposición ha criticado que hayan dejado
sus fuentes de trabajo para marchar en
favor del gobierno
luís arse en esta concentración ha
fustigado duramente a la derecha ha
señalado que sobre su cadáver volverá a
haber un golpe de estado en bolivia en
alusión al gobierno transitorio que se
instaló en el año 2019 también ha dicho
que la derecha sólo llega al poder para
llenarse en los bolsillos y que usa
cualquier excusa para desestabilizar a
su
y una jornada de marchas pacíficas sin
embargo también hubo un poco de tensión
en la zona de villa fátima porque ahí
están concentrados los cocaleros de los
yungas que protestan en contra de otro
sector de aquella región mire ahora de
dónde han salido estas declaraciones de
arse que acusa a la derecha de querer
desestabilizarlo
pues estas declaraciones tienen que ver
con dos conflictos que están en curso en
bolivia actualmente uno de ellos es por
el censo de población y vivienda el
departamento de santa cruz que tiene un
gobernador opositor quiere que el censo
se realice el año 2023 mientras que el
gobierno ha fijado una fecha para el
por eso santacruz ha hecho ya dos paros
de actividades un paro de 24 horas y
otro de 48 horas entretanto los
cocaleros de los yungas y llevan
concentrados en la paz por cuarta semana
consecutiva
realizando protestas en contra de otro
sector y de un mercado de coca paralelo
que se ha instalado en esa zona ellos
castigan al gobierno porque dicen que es
el gobierno el que apoya a este sector
paralelo y piden el cierre de ese
mercado diariamente hay protestas y
además de enfrentamientos con la policía
y este sector esos son los dos motivos
que llevan al presidente ar se afirmar
que en bolivia está en curso una
desestabilización en contra de su
gobierno